Things started looking up.
One of the first orders of business was to build a peace with the local Indians.
The Indians were suspicious of the Pilgrims...
...because there were previous run-ins with Englishmen that ended badly.
Some Indians have been kidnapped and killed,...
...and diseases brought by visiting English had even wiped out entire villages.
But to their credit, the Pilgrims were wise in diplomacy...
...and had a high view of the Indians.
They sought long-term peace with their neighbors,...
...and with the help of Squanto, an English-speaking Indian,...
...they reached an accord with Wampanoag chief Massasoit,...
...an agreement honored by both sides for their lifetimes.
That summer was filled with building homes, planting crops, hunting, and fishing.
Squanto and other Indians were helpful in teaching the Pilgrims...
...the skills that they needed to survive.
The first fall delivered a super abundance of every kind of food.
It had been an amazing year, and finally, things were looking up,...
...and, well, it was time to party.